(upbeat music)
- [Girls] Happy smoothie day!
- Happy smoothie day!
Have we ever had such a
healing tradition as this?
- So healthy and so smart!
- You go first baby!
- Okay, here we go.
Massaged kale!
We got some bluebs,
otherwise known as blueberries.
- Bluebs, like blue boobs.
- Like getting blue boobed.
Banana!
- Sweet.
- Low fat yo-gert.
Ice.
And I'm going to tell you
that you're always late.
(blender whirring)
My time matters,
eye shadow is very heavy.
(blender whirring)
Not doing it in
front of a mirror.
- Good.
- Great.
- It looks yummy.
I should get started on mine.
Starting with yams,
gonna do some blackberries.
That makes the
smoothie expensive.
Bee pollen.
- Bee pollen?
- So that I live forever.
- Where ya goin',
the farmer's market?
- Blend it up with some ice.
- Witchy.
- And coconut water,
I'm Rihanna, bitch!
- Electrolytes.
- Yes!
- The most important thing,
mah-cah.
- What's mah-cah?
- Turn on the blender.
(blender whirs)
I've told you about
mah-cah so fucking much.
(blender whirs)
My jam right now.
But you don't seem to hear.
That's a relief.
- You know, looking at mine,
it looks a little chunky.
- You know what,
mines not chunky enough.
- I think I need
to add some ice.
(girls yelling
over blender whir)
You're not showering every day.
(girls yelling
over blender whir)
You feel uncomfortable.
- [Girl In Yellow] Good.
- Looks great.
- Drink up baby.
- Cheers.
- We have a perfect friendship.
- We really do.
(upbeat music)
- We could maybe do
this twice a year.
A semi-annual smoothie day.
- Yeah, couple times,
maybe couple times a month.
(upbeat music)